Dr. Jack Bright is a man known by many names,
and whether that name is“Oh God No” or
just Jack, if you’ve spent any amount of
time here on SCP Explained, you’ve surely
at least heard of the good doctor one or twice.
He’s a high-ranking senior staff member
at Site-19, one of the Foundation’s most
notable facilities, and has served as a director
and important member of the Foundation’s
upper ranks for decades.
Of course, you wouldn’t be able to tell
that by looking at him, because depending
on the current circumstances, Dr. Bright might
not look a day over 13, or 80, or 90, or he
might just be a chimpanzee.
This is because Dr. Bright, in his younger
days, came into contact with SCP-963, a metal
amulet that gives its wearer’s consciousness
immortality.
When the amulet is moved from one body to
another, Dr. Bright’s consciousness moves
with it, allowing him to occupy a variety
of bodies, from animals to old ladies, Dr.
Bright has been them all.
Heck, Bright’s body-swapping abilities have
even proven themselves to be incredibly useful
for the Foundation, so the guy’s able to
get some actual work done when he’s not
goofing off.
In undercover operations, Dr. Bright has been
used to infiltrate areas that the Foundation
would typically have trouble reaching, or
where clandestine operations are the best
course of action.
In the 2000 United States Election, Dr. Bright
briefly occupied the body of George Bush in
order for the Foundation to investigate political
opponent Al Gore’s activities without suspicion.
But that mess is a story for another day.
Today, we’re going to be taking a look at
a different side of Dr. Jack Bright.
One that isn’t so overt, one that’s lurking
behind the joking facade and silly antics
so commonly associated with Bright’s identity.
This is SCP Explained, and we’d like to
welcome you into the complicated, dramatic,
and ultimately tragic world of the Bright
family, specifically, the story of SCP-590.
Your consciousness being immortal certainly
has its perks.
For one, you can’t die!
On the other hand, you can’t die.
We all know the old cliche about immortality,
how your friends and loved ones will grow
old and die off while you’ll stay the same
age.
How centuries will start to feel like months.
How your mind will eventually crumble under
the weight of countless years and experiences,
because no man was made to live this long.
But while it’s a cliche for us, it’s reality
for Dr. Bright.
He’s painfully aware of how futile his situation
is, and behind closed doors, it scares him.
Dr. Bright struggles intensely with existential
depression, and for good reason too, right
now he might be fine, but in the relatively
near future, he’ll start experiencing that
cycle of death and rebirth of those around
him and himself, and over time, that cycle
will just keep repeating.
Body after body, friend after friend, tragedy
after tragedy, in the long term, Dr. Bright
knows that his life cannot have a happy ending.
It’s most likely because of this biting,
inevitable future that Bright makes the most
of his time with those around him in the Foundation,
making himself known as a charming, goofy
personality brimming with quirks and zaniness.
The part of Bright that makes others laugh
does so because deep down, Bright needs something
to take his mind off of his situation.
He wants the same type of familiarity and
comfort that he brings to other people.
But Bright’s public-facing persona is often
torn to shreds in private.
On top of being an undying soul, Bright has
to contend with an even more stressful experience:
his family.
The Bright family is a colorful assortment
of old blood that has run the inner circle
of the anomalous world for generations.
There are members of the Bright family that
were there when the First Administrator signed
the policy that created the SCP Foundation,
members who served time on the Overseer Council,
and even those who operate outside of the
parameters of the Foundation.
Dr. Bright is just one among many other individuals
of major anomalous significance in his bloodline,
and it’s only fitting that every family
has its issues.
For the Brights, all strong personalities
who hold positions of power in various places
across the anomalous world, unity isn’t
exactly a strong point.
In fact, most of the family isn’t anywhere
near each other, each member existing in their
own bubble, working towards their own individual
goals that often do not align with the rest
of their kin.
But there are occasions when the Bright Family
all come together to sneer at one another
from across a table and enjoy a nice, loving
reunion, though these meetings are often called
out of necessity, and are far and few between.
This gathering of anomalous individuals is
deemed important enough by the Foundation
to have its own designated security term,
nicknamed “Code Brown”.
When a Code Brown is issued, it can only mean
that the Brights are locked away in a room,
convening, arguing, and scheming over something
of great importance to them, and the rest
of the world should stay out of their family
business.
And when Jack Bright got his latest call for
a family meeting from one of the family members
he was on speaking terms with, he could only
think of just how bad of an idea that was.
It had been quite some time since Bright saw
the rest of his family, and he didn’t particularly
look forward to when they would meet again.
In the time since then, Bright had been taking
care of TJ, his younger brother, whose story
is nearly as tragic as Jacks.
Don’t worry, we’ll get back to the events
of the family reunion soon enough.
For now, let’s have a look at TJ Bright.
TJ was a product of the cruel, brutal attitude
the early Foundation took out on the objects
it contained.
Needlessly cold containment procedures that
denied basic needs for human anomalies, pointless
tests that often resulted in death or worse,
and a general lack of regard for decency or
ethics.
This archaic era would come to an end upon
the formation of the Ethics Committee, a board
formed in the upper ranks of the Foundation
that would enforce a better treatment of the
objects contained by the organization, with
severe consequences for those that disobeyed
the new, more humane doctrine.
But in the case of TJ Bright, there was nothing
the Committee could do.
TJ, who had been given the designation of
SCP-590 long ago, was an ordinary person who
happened to have anomalous abilities, like
countless others that the Foundation had dealt
with before.
He appeared to be permanently 16 years old,
never aging or changing in appearance once
during his time in containment.
The abilities in question that had caught
the attention of the Foundation were TJ’s
inherent power to cure illness.
Physical, mental, injuries, and wounds, TJ
could cure them all with just a touch of his
hand.
But at an unfortunate cost.
Whatever injury TJ would cure, it would be
mirrored onto his own body.
A giant, gaping wound could be healed by TJ,
but the aftereffects of such, such as scar
tissue and any lasting side effects, would
later appear on his own body, leaving the
boy to feel the pain of everyone he touched
and healed.
The early Foundation needlessly exploited
SCP-590’s abilities in tests and procedures,
testing the limits of TJ’s body and its
abilities.
This, of course, was carried out without the
knowledge of his brother, Dr. Bright, who
at the time did not have enough pull or power
within the organization to save his brother.
He could only watch and hope that one day
SCP-590 could live a better life outside of
his cell, as TJ Bright, and not a number on
a placard to be experimented with so casually.
The Foundation’s experiments with TJ sometimes
involved the use of SCP-500, an all-curing
panacea that would fully heal SCP-590, and
bring him back to full health, a state that
would later be reverted when the Foundation
started their experiments with the boy once
again.
TJ had endured immeasurable pain, and as a
result had suffered a broken, mental state
over the years.
As time went by, and things within the Foundation
had started to change, including Jack Bright’s
prominence, he worked as hard as he could
to push through bureaucratic red tape and
work out a solution that would leave TJ in
a less torturous position.
And when the time came, it was Jack Bright
who made the call to have SCP-590 cure a variety
of specific mental conditions that would leave
the boy in a dulled state, unable to fully
comprehend the pain he endures, should the
Foundation ever have to utilize TJ’s abilities
again.
Bright’s decision to do this to his brother
was questionable, and a part of the doctor
regrets it to this day, but at the time, it
seemed like a more preferable option than
having SCP-590 be fully aware of what was
happening to him.
Unfortunately, the idea that TJ’s reduced
mental capacities would prevent him from understanding
what was occuring to him was a misunderstanding,
and TJ was still more than capable of perceiving
what was happening to him, and that was pain.
He knew he was being hurt, he knew he wasn’t
loved, and even though his mind was unlike
Brights or those who experimented with him,
he felt the same things they did.
By the time of the reunion, TJ was fully in
the care of Dr. Bright.
Eventually, the modern Foundation worked out
that it was doing the poor boy more harm than
good to keep him locked up in a cell all day,
and Bright, who was now one of the most notable
and important individuals in the Foundation,
was able to pull enough strings to get TJ
out of confinement.
Now, he could truly rest without worry that
he would be exploited and abused, safe alongside
his older brother.
Inside the meeting room, all of the famous
figures of the Bright family, well, the ones
that were alive at least, were there.
Dr. Bright sat alongside TJ, who occupied
himself with a coloring book and a set of
crayons.
From across the table was Mikell Bright, better
known as Overseer O5-6, a former Foundation
agent who operated under the name of ‘Cowboy’.
O5-6 was a hardened individual, with a heavy
interest in firearms and a whole lot of luck
on his side.
Mikell and Jack, almost at the same time,
both fired out remarks about how bad of an
idea they felt this reunion was.
The one who called the reunion was their elder
sister, Claire Bright, whose aged body felt
notably out of place among the collection
of forever-young Brights, whether it was Jack’s
body-hopping, TJ’s longevity, or Mikell’s
use of SCP-006, the Overseer Council’s “Fountain
of Youth”, to keep himself young for an
extended period of time.
Also present was Yoric Elroy, Jack Bright’s
grandson, and a man who always happened to
be at the right place at the right time, even
if he himself felt that it was wrong.
As the three of them discussed the state of
Claire Bright’s apparent aging situation,
Yoric remarked that he thought she was involved
with that incident at Site-23.
This, Dr. Bright knew, was referring to an
incident he’d rather forget, where a reality
bender contained by the Foundation attempted
to give the Bright family, himself, Mikell,
and TJ included, a happy ending, where they
would be cured of their ailments and allowed
to live ordinary lives.
Of course, this was just the product of a
reality bend, and the fantasy quickly fell
apart when the Brights realized what was going
on.
Jack rathered not dwell on what could have
been.
Across from Yoric was Foundation Agent Serra
Argent, one of the younger members of the
Bright family, who worked as the Overseer
Council’s Hand Sinister, a special title
granted to an assassin used by the Council
to sort out messy business for them.
The previous Hand Sinister was none other
than Mikell Bright, whose pearl revolvers
that came with the position now belonged to
Serra.
Mikell was growing impatient and asked how
long it would take for the rest of the family
to show up.
The rest of the family being the Brights that
weren’t involved in the Foundation.
The powerful individuals who had worked their
way into various groups of interests and aspects
of the anomalous world.
While some directly opposed the Foundation
and its mission and others were neutral, they
were all Brights, which meant that their presence
was necessary.
While the two sides sometimes worked together,
there was always an air of bad blood and poor
trust between them.
Dr. Bright in particular was not looking forward
to the rest of this meeting.
The first to arrive was an individual named
Nobody, who the Foundation had a difficult
time keeping up with.
Nobody was a title granted from one person
to the next, who each worked towards a greater
plan that only Nobody knew the specific details
of, leaving the Foundation completely unaware
of the group’s larger interests.
Nobody’s voice was impossible to source,
and her appearance was even harder to pin
down, but she was there.
Nobody circled around the table, remarking
that the other side of the family had sent
her first to make sure that the Foundation
Brights were all abiding by the rules.
At one point in time, Nobody did have another
name, but in becoming the next Nobody, she
left her previous life all behind.
The next to arrive was Claire Lumineux the
Second, a human with electromagnetic abilities
whose motives were largely unknown.
When she pulled back the chair to sit down,
sparks flew in the air, briefly startling
the rest of the room.
After that came David Blindman, a gruff, sunglasses-wearing
member of the Serpent’s Hand, a group of
anomalous individuals who work to free anomalies
from the confinements of the Foundation, who
they call jailers.
Blindman was Mikell’s son, and possessed
the anomalous ability to see into the future.
He was the unofficial representative of the
Unnumbered Brood, a subsection of the Bright
family consisting of Mikell's illegitimate
children from his wilder days as a free-roaming
Foundation Agent, and a constant reminder
to the overseer of his past.
Naturally, Mikell was less than pleased to
see his son arrive.
And then there was Evelyn Navon, who levitated
into the room wearing a traditional hijab
and dress.
Evelyn was one of the original 13 founding
members of the SCP Foundation, and the matriarch
of most of the Bright family.
Unfortunately, Evelyn was kicked off of the
Council for reasons unknown, but rumor has
it that it had something to do with her terrible
experiments as a genius geneticist, creating
monsters by splicing the DNA of the ordinary
and the anomalous.
She’s sold her work to groups of interest
such as Dr. Wondertainment or Prometheus Labs,
who benefited from having such fine test subjects
to work with.
Her current activities are largely unknown,
but as the rest of the family knew, they couldn’t
be anything good.
The final member of the Bright Family to enter
was the only one who was trusted by all of
them, and that was a man of many names, who
was most commonly referred to as Tamlin.
Tamlin was a mysterious individual who existed
for centuries, far longer than any other member
of the family.
He had something to do with time, but no one
was quite sure what it was that he did, but
they all knew that he was important, and that
he was the only one who attempted to keep
peace and balance between the various factions
of the family.
Tamlin took a mental count of the room, realized
everyone was present, and addressed them all,
ready to explain why they were there.
Collectively, the family came to realize that
the one who called the meeting, Claire Bright,
was not there.
Tamlin solemnly explained that she had passed
away, and he had called the family together
in her stead to present a video tape containing
her dying wish.
The tape was concocted through Claire and
Tamlin’s time shenanigans, and featured
a recording of Claire who, through Tamlin’s
abilities to travel through and control time,
was able to respond and interact with the
members of the family in the room.
As morbid as Dr. Bright felt this was, he
would make sure to treasure this final interaction
with his sister.
Claire’s recording contained her will, and
with Tamlin’s help, she distributed gifts
to the other members of the family, final
remembrances she had collected from across
the anomalous world for them to cherish.
An egg with a universe inside of it for Evelyn.
The literal sword of Damocles to hang over
Mikell’s head.
Jack Bright’s first-ever bottle of whiskey
that he made so many years before.
Documents she entrusted to her daughter, Claire
II.
When it came time for TJ’s gift, however,
the boy suddenly grew serious and declined
it.
The recording of Claire understood, and stated
that if he didn’t want it, then she would
instead have Tamlin give it to someone who
needed it.
Dr. Bright could only wonder what it was that
she had planned to give TJ, but it seemed
like the boy’s selfless nature had won again,
and he was unable to accept it.
After the gifts had been distributed, the
tape cut out.
Tamlin stated that this was all that Claire
had recorded, and that she wanted her death
to bring the family together once again, to
remind them that they were family.
Claire’s sincerity had brought the room
to silence, each member of the family engaged
in deep thought.
As Tamlin gave parting remarks, one by one,
each member left.
Mikell was embarrassed by the ordeal, immediately
trying to revert back to his Overseer mindset,
but he couldn’t.
Claire’s loss was already affecting him.
In the end, there was only Tamlin, who left
a single blue rose on top of the VCR player
that contained Claire’s recording in remembrance
of someone he felt almost understood him.
As Dr. Bright left the meeting, he still felt
conflicted about his family, but at the very
least, he felt there was progress being made.
After all, they had all been in the same room
for more than 10 minutes without trying to
kill one another.
He glanced at the boy at his side, wondering
if he made the right decision all those years
ago.
While that much, and most of his job with
the Foundation was uncertain, he knew one
thing for a fact: he had to protect TJ.
Now go check out “SCP Immortal Dr. Bright
Explained” and “SCP-963 What Would You
Do If You Were Immortal Like Dr. Jack Bright?”
for more of the wacky world of Jack Bright!